thanks for having me so today I am going
to be talking about how to go from zero
users who many users I'm just assuming
that you have many great ideas in your
head at this moment and you're kind of
thinking about what the next step is so
I wrote this up early this morning and a
lot of this is based off of mistakes
I've made in the past so as Sam
mentioned I went through YC in 2010 and
spent a number of three years basically
going back and forth pivoting a bunch of
time starting over a bunch of times and
have learned a lot about what not to do
if I were to start another startup after
homejoy if that should ever happen and
so a lot of it comes from failure and
just telling you about what you
shouldn't do and kind of making
generalizations of what you should do
from that so just a reminder that this
is sort of you know all advice you
should take as directionally good
guidance like it's all it's like it's
kind of in the right direction but every
business is different you are different
I'm not you and so just take everything
with you know that in mind so this is a
college course you know when you start a
startup you should basically have lots
of time on your hand to concentrate on
the startup and I'm not saying you
should you know quit school or you
should quit work what I'm saying is you
should have a lot of time compressed
time in are in a row really dedicated to
immersing yourself in the idea and
developing problems or developing the
solutions to the problem you're trying
to solve so for example if you're in
school you know it's better to have one
or two days straight of per week I'm
working on your idea versus you know
spending two hours here and there every
single day during the course of the week
it's sort of like I think this is
engineering class so it's sort of like
coding like there's a lot of context
switching and and just you know what the
really focus really really focused
immerse yourself is very very important
so like I said I sort of first when I
wrote this up was thinking what is
what are the things that most people
some people do or most people do that is
not the correct way to do a startup and
sort of the novice approach I think is
what you see up here which is you know I
have this really great idea I don't want
to tell anyone about it
I'm gonna build build build build I'm
gonna maybe tell one or two people and
then I'm gonna launch it on you know I'm
gonna watch it on TechCrunch or
something somewhere like that then I'm
gonna get lots of users but what really
happens is because you did not get a lot
of that feedback and stuff like that you
know maybe you'll get a lot of people to
your site but no one sticks around
because you didn't get that initial user
feedback and then you know if you you
know if lucky enough you have some money
in the bank you might go buy some users
but sort of it just whittles out over
time and you just give up and it's a
sort of official cycle and you know I
actually did this once and I did this
while I wasn't YC and that was you know
like when I went through oh I see I
didn't even launch a product like I
didn't even launch on TechCrunch which
is the thing that you should definitely
do and and so you don't want to ever get
into that cycle because you'll just end
up with nothing good so the next thing
is you know you have an idea and you
should really think about what the idea
is really solving like what is the
actual problem and so their problem
statement should you should be able to
describe in one sentence and then you
should think how does that problem
relate to me am I really passionate
about that problem and then you should
think okay it's a problem I have is it a
problem that other people have and sort
of verify that by you know just going
out and talking to people one of the
biggest mistakes I've made is you know
we started my co-founder and I who is
also my brother he and I started a
company called path joy in 2009 2010 and
our goal was basically to you know we
have two goals in mind one is to create
a company that made people really happy
and and
create a company that was very very
impactful and so a good proxy for that
is to just create a huge big company and
so we thought okay here's the you're
sort of we're going to saw
all this you know make people happier
and our we first went to the notion of
who are the people that made people
happy and we you know we came up with
life coaches and therapists so it seemed
kind of obvious to just create a
platform for life coaches and therapists
and what happened as a result though was
that you know when we started using the
product ourselves we we you know we're
not cynical people by any means but life
coaches and therapists are just not
people we would use ourselves it was
sort of useless to us and so it wasn't
even a problem we had and certainly
wasn't something we're super passionate
about building out yet we spent you know
almost a year trying to do this and so
if you just start you know from Tegel
zero just like think about this before
you even build any product I think you
can save yourself a lot of headache down
the road from doing something you don't
want to do so say you have a problem and
you're able to state it where do you
start like how do you think of solutions
so the first thing you should do is
think of what the industry that you are
getting yourself into whether it's big
whether it's huge you should really
immerse yourself in that industry and
there's a number of ways to do this one
is you know to really become a cog in
that industry for a little bit and so it
might seem a little counterintuitive to
do this because most people say you know
if you really want to disrupt an
industry you should really not be this
you know player in it you should you
know it you know someone who spent
twenty or thirty years in an industry
probably does you know sit in their ways
and is just used to the way things work
and really can't think about what the
inefficiencies are other things that you
can quote unquote disrupt but however as
a noob like coming into the industry you
really should take you know one or two
months just really understanding what
all the little bits and pieces of the
industry are and how it works because
it's one you get into the details that's
when you start seeing things you can
exploit things you can really things
that are really really inefficient and
provide you know huge overhead costs
that you can cut down and so an example
of this is
you know when we start at home joy when
we decided to go we started with the
cleaning industry and when we started
you know we just were cleaners ourselves
and we started to clean houses and we
found it really quickly was that we were
very bad cleaners and so as a result you
know we said okay we gotta learn more
about this and we went to buy books and
we bought books about how to clean which
helped maybe a little bit we learned a
little bit more about cleaning supplies
but it's sort of like basketball you
know you you can watch and you can learn
or you can watch and read about
basketball but you're not gonna get
better at it if you don't actually you
know training you know throw throw
basketball around and throw into the
hoop and so we decided one of us
basically have to go and learn how to
clean and so we went or get trained by
you know a professional sort of some
sort of professional training program if
that existed and that meant we actually
went to get a job at a cleaning company
itself and the cool thing was that you
know I learned how to clean from you
know training for the few weeks that I
was there at the cleaning company but
the even better thing was that I learned
a lot about how a local cleaning company
worked and in that sense you know I
learned why a local cleaning company
could not become huge like homejoy is
today
and that's because they have you know
they're pretty old school and they have
a lot of things just just from anywhere
from booking the customer to optimizing
the cleaner schedules was just done very
inefficiently and so there's so when you
go if you are in a situation like mine
where you know there's a service there's
a service element of it you should go
and do that service yourself you know if
you work if your thing is relate to
restaurants you should become a waiter
if it's related to you know painting you
know become a painter and kind of get in
the shoes of your customers from all
angles of what you're trying to build
the other thing is there's also level
obsessiveness
that you should have with it too as well
like you should
to be so obsessed to know like and what
everybody in the space is doing and it's
things like you know spreading a list of
all the potential competitors or similar
types of companies Google searching it
and clicking on every single link and
reading every single article from what
from likes search result number one to
one thousand you know I I found all
potential competitors big and small and
if they're public I would go read their
ass ones I would go I would read all
their quarterly financials I would you
know sit on the earnings calls there's
you know most of these you don't get
much out of it but there's just these
golden nuggets that you'll find once in
a while and you won't be able to find
that unless you actually go through the
work of you know getting all that
information in your head so yeah you
should become an expert in the industry
there should be no doubt when you're
building this that you are the expert so
that people trust you when you're
building this product the second thing
is identifying customer segments so you
know ideally at the end of the day in
the endgame you've built a product or a
business that everybody in the world is
using but realistically in the beginning
you kind of want to corner off a certain
part of the customer base so that you
can really optimize for them and that's
just you know it's just about matter of
focus and a matter of you know just you
know catering towards whether it's teen
girl teenage girls or whether it's you
know soccer moms you'll just be able to
you know like I said focus a lot on on
their needs and lastly before you know
before you even create the product
before you put code down you should
really storyboard out the ideal user
experience of how your have your gonna
solve the problem and that and that's
not just meaning you know the website
itself it's meaning you know how does
the customer find out about you you know
whether it's you know could be thrown
out or through a word-of-mouth or
whatever so they find out about you they
come to your site they learn more about
you what's all that text say what are
you communicating to them through the
actual when they sign up for the product
or they purchased the service what are
they actually getting to after they
finished using the product or actually
after they finished using the service
what's you know there's there's sort of
like an evaluation pair like they leave
your review or or they leave comments or
whatnot and just being able to go
through that whole flow and and
visualize in your head like just
envision what the perfect user
experience is and then put it down on
paper and then put it into code and then
start from there
so you have all these ideas in your head
now you kind of know what the core
customer base you want to go after is
and you know like everything about the
industry what do you do next so you
start building your products and you
know the common phrase that most people
use these days like you should build a
minimal vial the MVP Minimum Viable
Product and I underline viable because I
think a lot of people skip that part and
they just go out with a feature and then
the whole user experience in the very
beginning like is flat so no black
market viable product pretty much means
you know what is the smallest feature
set that you should build to solve the
problem that you're trying to solve and
I think if you go through the whole
storyboard experience you can kind of
figure out that very quickly but again
you have to be talking to users right
you have to be potential user you have
to be seeing in what is what exists out
there already and what you should be
building to solve their immediate needs
and the second thing is before you put
in things in front of a user you should
really have your product a simple you
know product positioning down and what
my what I mean by that is that you know
you should be able to go to you know a
person and you should be able to say hey
you know this does X Y & Z within a
sentence and so for example you know at
home joy we started off with something
actually super complicated we're like
we're an online platform for our home
services we started with cleaning and
you can choose you know blah blah blah
blah and it just went off for paragraphs
and paragraphs will you present and we
went to you know potential users to come
on our platform they just get kind of
get bored after their first first first
first few sentences and so what we do
what we found out
that you know we really needed this
one-liner the one-liner is very
important and it kind of describes the
functional benefit of of what you do you
know in the future when you're trying to
build a brand or whatnot you should you
should you know be able to describe you
know what are the emotional benefits and
stuff like that but you're starting with
no users you really need to tell them
what they're going to get out of it so
we simply after we changed our
positioning to get your place clean for
$20 an hour then everyone got it and we
were able to get you know users to users
in the door that way so you have a MVP
going out there now how do you get your
first few users to start trying it so
your first few users should be you know
obvious people the people that you're
connected with you should use it
obviously a you and your co-founder
should be using it your mom and dad
should be using it your friends and
co-workers should be using it beyond
that you want to get more user feedback
and so you and I've listed here kind of
some of the obvious places to go to and
depending on what you're selling you
know you can take your pick of the pick
up the draw here so online communities
there's you know in hacker news now
there's the show HN that's a great place
especially if you're building tools for
developers and things like that local
communities so if you're building
consumer product you know there are a
lot of influential local community
mailing lists especially those for you
know parents so those are places you
might want to hit up to okay so when you
go to buy the wait homejoy
we actually tried all of these so we use
it ourself that was fine because I mean
we were on cleaner so that was pretty
easy and then our parents lived in
Milwaukee so we were based on mounting
you so that in work friends and
co-workers are kind of like in San
Francisco and elsewhere so we don't have
too many of them use it so we're
actually ended up in a dead end of not
being able to convince many people to
use this in the beginning so what we did
was because we're in Mountain View some
of you guys might know on caster street
they have street fairs there during
summertime and so we go out and
basically chase down people and try to
get from the book of cleaning and almost
everyone would say no until one day we
just took advantage you know it's a very
hot and humid day and what we noticed
was you know and this is like in any any
fair people you know there might be arts
and crafts things like that and random
people will you know gravitate towards
that but everybody gravitates towards
the food and drink area especially on a
hot day so what we did was okay we
needed we figured we need to get in the
middle of that and by getting in the
middle of that we just took water
bottles froze them and then we started
handing out free free bottles of water
that were cold and people just came to
us we I think we basically guilt trip
people into booking cleanings
but the proof in the pudding was that I
figured most of these people were
guilt-tripped into doing it but when
they went home they didn't cancel on us
well some of them did but a majority of
them did not and so we felt like I
thought okay that's good I got to go
clean their houses but at least you know
there's something we're actually solving
here so and you know I don't suggest I
think showing up the fares or I know
another startup in the last batch I
forgot their name right now but they
they showed up they were selling
shipping type products we're trying to
replace shipping products or the concept
of mailing stuff and so they would show
up to the US postal office and just like
find people who were trying to ship
products and just take them out of line
and try to get them to use your product
and have them ship before and so you
just have to go to places where people
aren't going to really show up and you
know your corrosion rate is going to be
really really low but to go from zero to
one to three to four these are kind of
things you might have to do okay so you
got some users using you now what do you
do with all these users
customer feedback so one the first thing
you should do is make sure there's a way
for people to contact
so support at home joy calm ideally
there's a phone number and if you put
hook of a phone number one really good
idea is to make sure that you have
voicemail or something like that so you
don't have to be picking it up all the
time but in case a way for people to get
in bound to get inbound feedback is good
but really what you should be doing is
going out to your users and talking with
them you know get away from your desk
and just get out and do the work it's it
seems like a slog and it's going to be a
slog but this is where you're going to
get the best feedback ever for your
product and this is going to teach you
on what features you need to completely
change get rid of or what features you
need to build and so one way to do this
is to send out surveys you know to get
reviews after they've used the product
this is okay but generally you know
people are only going to respond if they
really love you or they really hate you
and you never get like the in-between so
kind of get in between and not get all
the extremes is to go out and actually
meet the person that is using your
product and it's not a good idea to you
know I've seen people go out meet the
user and they sit there and it's like a
laboratory and it's it's like an
inquisition almost you're kind of just
like poking and poking and poking at
them like why don't you go and do that
that's not going to give you the best
results what you should really do is
make it into a conversation
get to know them give them feel
comfortable because you want to get them
at a level where they are they feel like
you know they should be honest with you
to help you and improve improve things
for you so I found that actually taking
people out for drinks and stuff like
that was a very good way to do that I'm
not sure if all of you're old enough to
do that but you can take them for coffee
so another way another thing you should
be tracking is how are you doing in
general at from like the macro
perspective and one way to do that the
best way to do that is by tracking
customer retention that is the number of
people that came in the door
today how many are coming back tomorrow
the next day and so on and so forth
usually over time you're kind of looking
at you know monthly retention so you
know people who came in the door today
are they still using it next month and
so on and so forth the problem with that
metric is that it's you know it takes
forever to collect that data and you
don't have sometimes you don't have a
month or two months or three months to
you know to figure that out so good
leading indicator is actually collecting
reviews and ratings like five star four
star reviews or collecting some notion
of NPS which is net promoter score
so you're basically asking them from a
rating from zero to ten how likely are
they become end you to a friend and
calculating the NPS and so over time
what you'll see is as you're building in
new features you should be able to see
that the reviews or the retention is
going up over time which means you're
doing a good job if it's going down
you're doing a bad job and it's kind of
staying the same that means you probably
need to go out and figure out what new
things you you should be building the
other thing is I've got to the
qualitative thing later but the one
thing you should be wary of is the
honesty curve which is some people will
just lie to you so I was gonna just just
just do it so I mean this is like
degrees of separation from from you and
this is like level of honesty like so
here it's here this is your mom this is
like your friends are friends and here's
like random people don't if you can all
see this but so your mom is going to be
you know they should use your product
but she's going to be proud of you
anyway and so she'll like maybe be
honest like this much and your friends
will you know they'll be pretty honest
with you and give you feedback because
they care about you by the way this is
assuming it's a free product that you're
giving them and then over time like as
you get more and more random these
people don't even know who you are it
doesn't go like this really but it kind
of goes like this
where people don't care about giving you
feedback they just like okay here's a
survey type tick tick tock
and so you should take this into
consideration when getting user feedback
now let's say you make you pay it's a
paid product right well let's just do
this in green so in the page you know
your mom is gonna be like down here like
she's just gonna lie to you and say you
know she's just gonna feel sorry and say
hey this is a great product of course
but then you kind of it goes like this
right which is to say that you know your
friends are kind of gonna give you the
right there they want to support you and
give you the right feedback but it's
actually these random people out here
that you know if if they if they really
don't think what they paid for was worth
it they're gonna really tell you because
you know it's money out the door
and so this is another way of saying
you're gonna get the best feedback like
this is obviously you know down here
you're gonna more feedback if you just
make someone pay for it
so that's not to say you know you should
you know the first time out make people
pay for it but is to say that you should
very if you're going to build a product
that you're gonna eventually need to you
know they're gonna pay for it for the
for the software for the hardware or
whatever you should do that get to the
point where you can do that very very
fast because then that's when you get
the real meaty stuff to help you in the
future of how you can get more paying
users in the door all right so you're
getting a lot of feedback and what do
you do before you want officially launch
the product so what you want to do is
you always want to be building fast
right and you want to be optimizing for
this stage of growth that is you know
you you might have 10 users at this
point don't there's no point in trying
to build features for the point when you
have a million users right you want to
optimize for the next stage of growth
which is going to be 10 to 100 users
like what are the features you really
need for that and just go with that
sometime and
and basically on the slide is just many
ways of studying that notion manual
before on animation one of the things
that I found when building a marketplace
is that process is very very important
over time as you scale but you need not
try to automate everything and create
software to just you know you know have
robots just run everything what you
really should do to understand what you
should build is to manually do it
yourself and and an example of this is
when we started taking on cleaning
professionals onto our platform we would
have them up but we would ask them a
bunch of questions over the phone and
then in person we asked them a bunch of
questions too and then they would go to
a test clean and then they would you
know get on boarded to our platform if
they were good enough and so this took a
doing all this question asking for that
many candidates you know we have about a
three to three to five percent
acceptance rate and so you can imagine
all the people we were talking to in the
beginning the funnel that never even
made onto the platform
but what happened over time was that we
learned certain questions that we were
asking were that were indicators of
whether they're going to be a good or
bad performer on the platform we through
just like data collection and just you
know looking at looking at everything we
could just ask on an online forum so
that's when we put on and put in an
online application they could apply and
then we would ask them maybe serve a lot
of the question is doing the
interpersonal interview so it's if you
try to automate things too fast then you
run into this problem potential problem
of you know not being able to move
quickly on trying to iterate you know
with things like questions on an
application and stuff like that and the
third point here is temporary brokenness
is much better than permanent paralysis
by that what I mean is you know
perfection is irrelevant during the
stage you should when you get to the
next stage of growth like what you're
trying to maybe perfect in this one
stage is probably going to
not matter anyway and so do not worry
about all the edge cases when you're
building something just worry about the
generic case of who your core user is
going to be and then as you get bigger
and bigger bigger the volume of those
edge cases will increase over time and
you'll want to you know built for that
and lastly beware of the Frankenstein
approach which is great you talk to all
these users they give you all these
ideas you know the first thing you're
going to want to do is go build every
single one of them and then go show them
the next day and make them happier you
should definitely listen to user
feedback but when someone tells you to
build a feature you shouldn't go build
it right away what you should really do
is you know get to the bottom of why
they're asking you to build a feature
it's usually usually what they're
suggesting is not the best idea but what
they're really suggesting is I have this
other problem that you've either created
from me while using the product or you
know I really need this problem solved
before I'm ever going to pay to use this
product and so figure that out first
instead of piling on a bunch of features
which then hides the problem altogether
so you have C so you have a product that
you're ready to ship and so some people
at this point will continue building
their product and not ship it at all and
I think the whole idea of being stealth
in you know perfecting the product to to
no ends is his idea that you know in
imitation is is is cheaper than
innovation and in terms of time and and
money in capital and so I think everyone
should just always assume in general
like there's gonna be if you have a
really good idea no matter when you
launch someone is going to someone's
going to be you know someone's going too
fast follow you and someone's going to
execute as hard as they possibly can to
catch up with you and so there's no
point in holding out and all that user
feedback that you can get by getting a
lot of users
because you feel like you know you feel
paranoid that someone's going to do this
to you and I hate to keep harping on it
but this is things I see today with
founders is something I went through as
well and I think unless you're unless
you're building something that requires
100 like tens of millions of dollars
just to start up there there's really no
point in waiting around to launch your
product so you have something that you
feel ready to get lots of users on so
what do you do at this point so I'll
look at my time so it's one minute okay
so I will go over various types of
growths in the next slide but the one
thing to note here early on when you are
trying to get when it's just you and
your co-founder and maybe like a couple
other people building you're not gonna
be you know create a team just for
growth it's gonna be one person in one
person only and so you need to really
focus and you need to you should only
you're gonna be tempted to try like five
different strategies at one time but
really what you should do is take one
channel and really execute on it for an
entire week and and just focus on that
and then if that works continue
executing on it until it caps out if it
doesn't work then just move on by doing
this you will feel more certain that
that that that that channel that you
were working on that initial hypothesis
is wrong you'll be you know then if you
tried only working a third of your time
on it over the course of you know three
or four weeks so learn one channel all
the time
second is always be it when you find
channels that work you find strategies
that work always be iterating on it you
can potentially give it to something
like create a playbook and give it to
somebody else to iterate on it but these
channels always change you know anything
from Facebook Ads to you know even
Google Ads to you know the the the
distribution channel is the environments
that you don't control change all the
time and so you should be always
iterating optimized
for that and lastly in the beginning
you're probably when you see a channel
that fails you you know just get rid of
it and go on and move on there's many
other things to try but over time go
back to those channels and and look at
it again so and what I mean by that as
an example is in the beginning at home
joy we had no money so when we try to do
we try to buy users from Mary made earth
not for Mary mates that's just an
example of competitor we tried to buy
Google Ads
to get users in the door quickly and
what we found was that Merry Maids mala
Maids all these other national companies
they have more money than us they were
making a lot more money on the job than
us and so they were able to pay for
users that are much higher and a much
higher CAC or Matar they were able to
acquire them at a much higher cost than
us and so we couldn't afford that and we
have to go to another channel which
turned out to be something else but
today you know we make more money on the
job we're much better at certain things
and so we should probably revisit the
idea of buying Google Ads and by you
know going to the SDM Channel and so
what that's what I mean by that and the
key to all this is creativity
performance marketing you know or
marketing or growth in general can can
be very technical but it's actually
technical and you have to be creative
because if if it wasn't if it was really
easy and bland you know like everyone
would be growing right now and so you
always have to find like that little
thing that no one else is doing and do
that to the extreme so there are three
types of growth when when yeah three
types of growth I'm sticky viral and pay
growth and hopefully I'll get enough
time to talk about all of this so really
briefly sticky growth is trying to get
your existing users to come back and pay
you more or use your more second is
viral growth so that's when people talk
about you so you use a product you
really like it then you tell to another
friend
they like it that's viral growth and the
third is paid growth so if you happen to
have money in the bank you're going to
be able to perhaps use part of that
money to to to buy growth and the
central theme I'm going to go through is
sustainability there's a lot of by
sustainable growth I mean you know
you're basically not a leaky bucket
money you put in or time you put in has
a good return on investment on it so
sticky growth is like I said getting
your existing users to keep buying stuff
so the only thing that really matters
here is that you deliver a good
experience right if you live a good
experience people are going to keep
wanting to use you if deliver an
addictive experience people are going to
keep wanting to use you and the way to
measure this and to really look at this
and how you're doing overtime of whether
you know you are providing good sticky
growth is to look at the clvs and
retention cordon alysus knows anyone not
know what cohort analysis is or should I
go over it okay so I'll go over it okay
so CLV is some people call LTV is called
customer lifetime which is basically the
amount of the net revenue that a
customer brings in the door for you over
a certain amount of period so a 12-month
CLV is how much net revenue does a
customer give you over 12 months and
sometimes people look at three months at
six months and so and so forth so so
when I say cohort basically what you're
looking at is this is time so let's just
call this yeah time so this is percent
of users coming back to you so at time
zero rate a period zero we're at a
hundred
100% so so cohort is is another name
also for like customer segments and
stuff like that so you can like you
might look at the female versus male
cohort you know people in Atlanta
Georgia error versus people in
Sacramento California but the most
common one is by by month so cohort
equals month and let's just say for this
exercise we are looking at like March I
don't know 2012 so March 2012 100% of
people you have like means N equals 100
people so 100% of the people obviously
are using your product because you know
that's the definition now
once one month later you might have you
know the skill is not right but 50%
might come back and so you come here now
in the second month how many people that
came in March come back in the second
month or two months later and that might
be you know down here and so over time
you'll have a curve that looks like this
there was always some initial drop-off
you know the reasons why people don't
stay after the first uses you know it
wasn't worth it had a bad experience
stuff like that and then over time what
you want is you want this to flatten out
over time so that your turn basically
goes to zero percent that means you
attrition out less less and less users
over time and these over here kind of
become your core customers these are
ones that are like sort of staying
staying with you for a long time and now
now court analysis or you know using
this as a way to show if you have sticky
growth or not is now say your say you
know say we're at one year later and
you've built a bunch of stuff right you
graph out
same thing and hopefully what you'll see
is that you have a curve like this that
is in the first period even more people
than 50 percent came back to you and
more more people are sticking with you a
really bad you know retention curve
looks like this which is like after the
first use they just hate you so much no
like no one even comes back it's just
let zero right and I don't know what
kind of business that is I mean it's
obviously a shitty business but like I
can't explain a good business that has a
retention curve like that so anyway so
our time as you are thinking of
strategies to increase this curve like
keep making go up and up and up you want
to basically look at this analysis over
time to see if if that strategy is
working for you okay does that make
sense okay cool
the second kind of growth is viral
growth and what like sticky growth you
need to also deliver a good experience
but on top of that you need to deliver a
really really good experience like
what's going to make these people shout
out loud on Twitter and Facebook
whatever and tell all their friends I'm
and email all the friends and family
members about you you have to really
deliver a good experience combined with
that is unite to have really good
mechanics for the referral program
itself like you have a hundred customers
who really want to talk about you now
how are they gonna talk about you so so
in that sense a viral growth chant the
Frog growth strategy is all really about
one building good experience but if you
have that it's how do you build a good
referral program and so I've listed the
three main parts of that one is the
customer customer touch points which is
where are people learning that they can
refer other people so that might be just
you know after they book or after they
sign up there is a you know usually you
see these like right after you sign up
for is in most for whatever reason most
people just immediately tell you to
invite all their friends even though
you've never use the product before and
so but that's a customer touch point
it's just right after you
not a better one is after they use the
product after a while and you see that
they're highly engaged then to show them
that link and get them to send it out to
everyone another one is if you're doing
more of a platform type play like for
home joy we actually go inside the homes
so now that customer touch point is when
the cleaning professional is inside the
home they can have leave behind and you
know we can show them something there
too as well
so you want to you want to basically put
the customer touch points and put the
actual link or whatever it is how
they're going to refer all their friends
at a point in time when they're highly
engaged and you know they're loving you
the second is program mechanics and so
that's sort of like you know the most
common thing I've seen is ten dollars
for ten dollars that is you get ten
dollars if you invite your friend and
they use it and they get ten dollars and
so you should and so you should try
different types of mechanics in that
sense and try to optimize for you know
whatever works for you you know it could
be 25 or 25 it could be 10 for zero it
could be in many many any of these
things and lastly it's you know when the
when your friend clicks on the link when
you know on your referral link when they
come back to the site it's very
important to really optimize that
conversion flow of how they're going to
sign up and so sometimes you need to
just sell them in a different manner or
upsell that the friend has has suggested
they use this and so and so forth so all
these combined you need to really play
around with what with these on different
dimensions and come with a good referral
program and lastly it's paid growth so
examples of pay growth is is this right
here and these are the most obvious ones
but I'm sure you guys can think of more
and pay growth is basically you know you
happen to have money you can spend you
might have credit cards whatever but you
can spend something to get users so the
correct way to think about paid growth
is that okay you're going to put money
you're going to risk putting money out
there what are you going to get in
return the simple way to think about it
is is your seal of the your customer
lifetime the amount of money the net
revenue
amount of money that people you know
that your customer returns back to you
is that more than your cat and your CAC
is and not its abbreviation for a
customer acquisition cost so an example
is you know you pay actually the slot
the slot the slide here has an example
here so say you run a bunch of ads
either for ads over over you know 12
months the customer is worth $300 to you
each one of these ads when you click on
it the CPC is costs this all this you
know cost different types of money and
then when they click on it so when they
click on the ad then they have to come
to your site and sign up or buy
something and the conversion rates are
different for all these ads and then you
know the CAC is calculated simply by the
CPC divided by the conversion and so you
see that there's different acquisition
costs for different types of ads and to
determine whether you know that is a
good at or badda you all you have to do
is you know CLV minus CAC is it more
than zero if it's at zero then you you
know you that that's fine but hopefully
it's actually more than zero and so you
actually are earning a profit on it
still we see that despite the CL B's
meaning the same and the conversions
being higher and lower they're sometimes
you know some ads that might seem good
actually don't seem so good at the end
of the day now the advanced way of
looking at it is this is you can look at
this for your whole entire customer base
for all you know aggregating all your
customers together but the advanced the
better way of looking at it is to break
it down by customer segments so you know
if you have for example if you're if
you're building a marketplace aren't you
for country music you know you the seal
of these of someone in Nashville
Tennessee is going to be much larger
than the CL of ease then Blake some
value of someone in Czechoslovakia so or
I just assume that's the case anyway so
you'll need to you want to make sure
that when you're buying ads for these
type different types of cohorts or these
types of custom
segments that you know what the
differences are and then you know you
don't want to mix like everything
together so the last point on payback
time is sustainability
you know I think a lot of businesses get
in trouble and it turns into a bad
business when they start spending beyond
their means and and it has a lot to do
with risk tolerance or risk you know how
much risk you're willing to take on so
when you look at these steal of these
let's just suppose you know you get a
customer for 300 you know customers were
$300 after twelve months that is in the
first month they're worth $100 if you
wait to the end of the twelve month
period then they give you the other $200
but if in the first period you're
actually paying you know $200 for them
then you're in the hole for $100 until
the end of the twelve month period and
that's when you start getting into
potentially unsustainable growth which
is something could happen where you know
at the end of the 12 months they
actually you don't actually get the 20
the the $200 from the customer and you
end up in a very bad situation and
essentially just at the end the day you
could be running out of money and if
you're doing this with credit cards you
will definitely find that you're gonna
have to you know declare bankruptcy very
soon so again
payback time is very important you know
a safe one to go with us three months if
you have very high risk if you're very
risk loving you know maybe 12 months is
better
beyond 12 months is very is very much an
unsafe territory okay how much time do I
have
I meant okay so I'll just go into this
so the art of pivoting so a lot of
people ask me you know homejoy went
through homejoy and it's
current concept is with was a literally
the 13th idea we fully built out and try
to execute on trying to get customers
for and so a lot of the questions I get
is how did you even like get to that
13th idea and how did you decide when to
you know move on and so the best
guidance I can give on that is to kind
of look at these three criteria which is
once you realize you can't grow or once
you realize you know despite you know
building out all these great features
and talking to all these users none of
them stick or none of them you know you
don't have any good high retaining users
or the economics of the business just
doesn't make sense then once you make
that realization you just need to move
on and I think the trickiest one is
probably the growth one because there's
so many stories out there where the
founder stuck with the idea and then
after three years all of a sudden it
started growing so the trick here is
basically what you really should do is
you should have a growth plan when you
start out which is you know you should
ideally just have what is what is that
what is an optimistic but realistic way
to grow this business and so it might
look something like this and this is
teeny and this is this is number of
users so you know in week one you want
you just want one user and week two you
want maybe two users and so and so forth
and you can keep doubling you know up
and up so in week one you should
basically do as much as possible don't
worry if the bill to get that one user
and then week two seven so forth you
know you you you build whatever you need
to get to users for users eight users in
the beginning its it should be fairly if
you have a product that people actually
want you should be able to maintain this
growth curve pretty easily just by
walking around and manually finding
people it's when you get to like you
need 100 users a week where you need
some of these more you need these growth
strategies to start working and so what
I tell people is usually if you're fully
executing
on on your product and you're really
working really really hard then if you
go three or four weeks in a row of no
growth backwards growth then either then
it's time to maybe consider a pivot in
the sense that not starting over like
completely come with a new idea but
you're probably fundamentally doing
something wrong because in that early
stage of a startup you should always be
growing and so it's not in this is
optimistically what it looks like and
the this is like kind of the growth
curve I set forth and put out when I
started homejoy
but really what looks like is like this
and so you want to make sure that when
you're in a lull like over here that you
don't just stop right and that's why you
should wait two to three weeks as long
as you keep working hard you'll
eventually get back here and you'll see
a trend like this over time cool
so that's pivoting and that's it I can
take questions at this point one
question right so there is always a
switchover cost I'll tell you the
example of home and joy so home joy we
actually worked creating a new market in
the sense that a lot of our initial
users never had cleanings before so it
was pretty simple to get them on board
and a lot of people who have cleaners
already really trust their cleaner and
they will you know it to get them to
come and use something else is actually
probably the most difficult task in the
world and so when you're when you're
building things in trying to get people
to switch over to you what you really
need to do is find the moments where
your product or what you're offering is
much better or very much differentiated
from the existing solution they have so
an example is someone who had a regular
cleaner and maybe they had a party one
day and they needed a cleaning almost
the next day and becomes homejoy
and most of the areas has next day avail
ability they would just come to home
join use it because they knew they
couldn't get their regular cleaner and
once they start using the product then
that's when they start realizing the
advantage the little advantages of using
homejoy which adds up to a big advantage
so you know a lot of things are you know
what realizing that you know leaving
cash out or leaving checks was really
annoying and so the only the online
payment was more convenient you know
it's a book cancel reschedule you know
according to your own schedule was very
convenient and so and so forth and so
it's just you know it's really hard to a
lot of people when they build a product
or like and these 50 things are better
than a little bit better than the
existing solution it's really hard even
if the benefits outweigh the switchover
cost it's really hard to actually tell
that to a user and try to get them to
aggregate all those you know benefits
over many little things it's better to
just have one or two things that clearly
differentiate yourself from the product
[Applause]
you